in ten days Destiny's here or should I
say I am where will you be when it all
ends I hope they remember you Avengers
infinity war [ __ ] pg-13
[Music]
it's a very interesting time now and boy
you don't know what's gonna happen I
know that I'm proud of it I know that
we've done everything we can
I really don't know how people are gonna
react to this thing this could be
anything from a flop to a moderate
single there's something that it's
beyond what people's expectations are
you never know you never know good luck
keeping on we were in our own slipstream
a feeling like we were doing something a
little bit special and different but the
full circle of seeing that audiences
were reacting to it the way we had hoped
they would was powerful
I had two dreams when we started this
little over 10 years ago more studio one
was that I meant working the other one
was that we could build something that
was as expansive and as experiential as
what people who read comics or viewers
could get I had a lot of faith and Kevin
Feige even people of Marvel you want to
give them everything you got cuz they're
gonna give everything they got this was
a whole new journey by the first
Avengers but I thought oh wow I think
we're onto something here just seeing
the characters together there's
something viscerally awesome about it I
think that's why the minute Sam Jackson
showed up at the end of Iron Man 1
whether people had very common or not
who is that what does that mean why is
he here and then Tony Stark appearing at
the end of the Incredible Hulk
mr. intelligent we were putting a team
together who's we
though it seemed like just the tiniest
of things compared to where we are now
but those were the foundations that led
us here the cutting edge concept behind
the Marvel Universe is this massive
organism of shifting parts and new ideas
how do we do this as a team Seraphin is
responsible for all of these amazing
actors and extras that we brought into
this I think after the first Avengers
people realized that this was not just
an ordinary comic-book movie that there
was really a lot of thought and a lot of
care and a lot of Pat
that's going into each and every one of
these films and there's also some joy I
think when the actors are having fun and
creating these characters and that
audiences feel that it's fulfilling that
those characters have just spoken to so
many people all over the world
[Music]
guru I love the fact that we've been
given the opportunity to do something
different put our set of ideas forward
and attack each character again and
hopefully advance on that and bring
something unique to it each time it's
wonderful to be able to play this iconic
character that means so much to people
and I really have to think the
audience's for that because they
embraced my portrayal of her from the
beginning final fitting what do you
think questions comments concerns and
allowed me to walk in Natasha's shoes
and kick ass in them too
I can tell you that each and every one
of us is so grateful
our lives are monumentally changed by
our involvement in this world to have
taken such an instrumental role in what
Marvel has done in the past ten years
it's just so incredibly meaningful to us
it's a cool experiment to be a partner
it's epic and classical these characters
are mythological characters in a lot of
ways I love all of you and I look
forward to seeing many of you as we
trudge this road of happy destiny it's
nice to look at how the legacy is living
on in these other movies and other
filmmakers I don't think this has ever
happened before in cinematic history of
all these different franchises colliding
and all these storylines they've started
such a long time ago have all woven
together you guys as the films have
progressed with civil war and now
infinity war we're just gonna continue
to surprise people
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more
[Music]
you
you